Salut ! On se retrouve donc pour la dernière vidéo de tous ces tutos pour réussir à résoudre un Rubik's Cube en moins de 2 minutes et avec seulement 5 formules.
On a vu ça les six derniers jours ensemble.
Aujourd'hui je fais un récap' un petit peu rapide, où vous me voyez le résoudre.
Et il y aura un petit bonus à la fin qui vous permettra de vous amuser encore plus avec un Rubik's Cube.
Alors évidemment, j'aurai pu vous parler d'autres techniques pour le résoudre, vous apprendre également plus de formules,
vous parler des figers tricks, qui est la manière dont on positionne les doigts pour aller encore plus vite dans la résolution du Rubik's Cube.
Mais vraiment, le but de ces vidéos c'était de vous apprendre déjà, à le réussir
pour vous familiariser aussi avec le Rubik's Cube.
Avec un peu d'entrainement en se basant sur les 6 vidéos précédentes, ça vous permet de résoudre ce Rubik's Cube !
[clac]
Une bonne fois pour toute.
Il faut que j'arrête de taper avec ! Pour l'anecdote, tout à l'heure j'ai tapé avec
et il s'est démonté.
Je vous recommande d'investir dans autre chose que le Rubik's Cube de base.
Il y a les V Cube, il y a pleins d'autres marques qui en font.
Prenez des Rubik's Cube qui tournent bien.
Déjà ça vous permettra d'aller plus vite, ça vous permettra aussi de ne pas vous perdre dans les formules,
et puis, clairement, c'est plus agréable.
Je vais partir de la phase blanche, comme ça on va s'y retrouver.
Comme j'ai déjà un blanc de placé, je vais le garder là...
Et je vais chercher celui qui va à coté.
A savoir, celui-ci.
Le blanc et vert.
Que je place en face.
Là il me faut l'autre angle où il y a du vert, et qui se situe là pour le moment, donc on va le ramener ici...
Comme ça j'ai ma première ligne, et je vais chercher à la compléter avec le rouge qui est là.
Voilà. Et puis un autre angle, celui-ci, c'est très bien.
Voilà. Le bleu, il s'est positionné tout seul, on ne va pas demander plus.
Je vais placer le orange dans la foulée, parce qu'il n'est pas loin.
Et ensuite le dernier.
C'est celui-là.
Ça c'est qu'on avait vu le premier jour.
A savoir, faire sa première face, avec la première couronne.
Ensuite, il faut qu'on fasse correspondre les centres de chaque face avec la première couronne.
Ça, c'était quand même le plus facile. On avait vu ça, le jour 2.
Et maintenant on va mettre en place ces 4 cubes là, donc ces 8 faces.
Là, j'ai du vert et du rouge, donc je vais me palcer pour l'instant sur le vert.
Le rouge étant ici, il faut que je l'emmène à gauche.
Donc j'applique la formule qui me permet d'aller à gauche.
Voilà, il est placé là.
Et je vais commencer à identifier les autres.
Là j'ai un vert/orange.
Donc c'est très bien. Je vais le placer ici...
Ok.
Il me reste le bleu et rouge, et là c'est impeccable.
Et là, le dernier sera le orange/bleu.
Qui doit être ici.
Exactement.
Toujours avec les formules qu'on avait vu, ensemble, le deuxième jour.
Ce qui nous permet de réaliser la deuxième couronne.
Maintenant, on cherche à avoir la croix.
Et souvenez vous, là je suis dans mon cas idéal,
où j'ai ce petit logo là.
Donc je le place en haut à gauche par rapport à moi.
Et je fais:
Droite inversée, Haut inversé, Avant inversée, Haut, Avant, Droite.
Pour avoir la croix de positionnée.
Et là ça ne m'arrange pas dans la vidéo, puisque tout est bien en place.
Alors, attendez, je vais casser ça.
Voilà.
J'ai volontairement cassé ça, parce que sinon ça me faisait sauter une technique.
Des fois ça arrive que tout se mette bien en place, ça c'est le hasard des mélanges de départ.
Donc on a réalisé la croix, maintenant il faut que les centres de la troisième couronne correspondent aussi à la deuxième et première couronne.
Donc là pour le vert, c'est bon.
Le bleu est en face du rouge.
Le orange est bon.
Le rouge est en face du bleu, c'est n'importe quoi.
Donc je vais placer le rouge en face du rouge, et le mettre à ma gauche comme ça le bleu ira lui, devant,
le orange ira ici,
et le vert ira là.
La formule, vous vous souvenez:
DH /D H D H² /D H²
Et ils sont en place.
Avant dernière étape. Maintenant il faut que je place les coins au niveau des trois faces qui correspondent.
Donc ce n'est pas le cas pour lui.
C'est pas le cas pour lui.
Est-ce que c'est le cas pour lui ?
Non plus.
Parce qu'il n'y a pas de rouge sur l'une de ces trois faces.
Et là non plus.
Donc il n'y a aucun de bon, comme ça c'est réglé !
Je vais appliquer la formule:
G /D H/G /H D HG /(HG)
Voilà.
Là, je regarde ce que ça donne.
Ici ce n'est pas bon.
Il c'est pas bon.
Ici c'est pas bon.
Mais ici c'est bon.
Celui-ci, je vais le préserver, le sauvegarder en le mettant le plus loin de moi et à ma gauche.
Et je réapplique la formule.
Je vérifie que tout correspond bien.
C'est le cas.
Si ça n'avait pas été le cas, j'aurai encore appliqué la formule.
Et maintenant on va le terminer ce Rubik's Cube.
Grace à ce qu'on avait vu, déjà auparavant:
DH /D H D H² /D H².
A laquelle on réapplique l'inverse de ce qu'on vient de faire:
/(DH) D/H /DH² DH².
Il nous reste plus que ces deux là.
Donc ceux qui sont bons je les laisse à ma droite,
ceux que je vais bouger, je les mets à ma gauche.
Les deux bleus.
Et je réapplique encore ça.
Et voilà un Rubik's Cube de réglé.
Si j'avais été un peu plus vite, sans prendre le temps de vous expliquer et de faire les gestes un peu lentement,
je l'aurai résolu en moins de 2 minutes.
Après c'est dur de descendre en dessous de 2 minutes avec ces méthodes là.
Et j'ai utilisé que 5 formules !
Je vous avait promis un petit bonus avant de partir.
Sachez qu'il existe des trix qu'on peut faire avec. Donc ce sont des figures spéciales avec le Rubik's Cube.
Par exemple faire une couleur différente au centre de chaque face.
Moi, je vais vous apprendre à faire le damier.
Le damier, c'est le plus simple à faire.
Vous allez adoré le faire.
Il se base sur les 180°.
Vous prenez une face vers vous, n'importe laquelle.
Et vous allez faire un 180° sur les 2 lignes extérieures et les deux colonnes extérieures.
Donc ça va donner:
clac clac
Et pareil, la même chose pour les lignes.
Lignes inférieures et extérieures.
Là on a un damier ici.
Là non.
Là oui.
On retourne le cube à un endroit où on a que des lignes, parce que tout le reste c'est des lignes.
On met les lignes en colonnes par rapport à nous.
Et on applique encore 180° sur les deux lignes.
On en a fait deux de plus, et ça a automatiquement fait les deux dernières faces.
Ce qui fait que maintenant, on a un magnifique damier !
Et si je voulais le repasser en cube de départ, il me suffirait de refaire 180°, six fois à six endroits différents.
Comme on a fait, pour le tranformer en damier.
Voilà, c'était la dernière vidéo sur le Rubik's Cube.
J'espère vraiment que ça vous aura plu.
J'espère que vous allez vous y mettre.
Comme je vous le disais hier, j'ai tournée toutes ces vidéos, début avril, au YouTube Space.
Merci à eux, à toute l'équipe de m'avoir accueilli et d'avoir le bistrot à disposition pour filmer.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine. Vous pouvez commenter dans la vidéo.
Si vous avez des questions à propos du Rubik's Cube, ou sur d'autres méthodes, ou sur d'autres formules, je me ferai un plaisir de vous y répondre.
Quand je rentrerai de vacances, si je suis en vacances.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H, si on est en semaine, ou à 11H si on est en week-end. Prenez soin de vous.
Ciao !